All right.
So welcome to the green glow--
psych ward.
[rain pouring]
I'd rather be just
about anywhere but
inside this shelter right now.
These rainy days are brutal.
It's cold.
I don't want to go outside.
I don't want to be in here.
And it's just a monotonous day.
It's going to be tough.
Need my blue sky for
my mental health.
How in the world did I
survive Vancouver Island?
I don't know.
I had a white tarp,
for one thing.
Huge difference, white tarp.
Not this green psych ward
shelter I'm living in.
It's not good-- not
good for the mind.
Just sitting here
staring at the fire.
Hoping the rain slows down
or stops today at some point,
so I can get outside.
[rain pouring]
I'm pretty sick of myself.
Yep.
Had all about enough
of me as I can stand.
[laughs] Woo!
It's a party.
Party of one!
That's me.
You know, I don't think it's--
the rain is
lightening up at all.
I don't think the
sky is, either.
[rain pouring]
It's my wishful imagination.
I'm not sure how much
more I can handle today.
Hey, guys.
Turns out I'm pretty sick
of hanging out with myself.
And I'm pretty lonely.
It-- it gets to
you after a while.
Just the quiet of not
sharing the experience--
it just kind of
eats away at you.
[sobbing] And, uh,
starving sucks.
[laughs]
It has been so
incredibly humbling to go
through this twice.
I feel like this time, because I
was alone instead of with Dave,
it's a bit of redemption.
It's a bit of a chance
to prove on my own
the skills that I have.
But there is this recollection
of Vancouver Island.
I don't want to go there again.
I don't want to get
that hungry again.
This is enough hungry.
This is enough cold.
This is enough loneliness.
It's enough of
the green monster.
It's like, OK, this is over.
Leave with a smile on my face.
And that's what I choose.